all right joining us now with more South
Carolina Senator Lindsey Graham is with
us uh I think I like this a lot maybe we
should have Lindsey Graham let me finish
uh let me finish you know they call it
what about us and that's the new
favorite phrase of the left and the
media and Democrats now what about ism
is it about equal justice an equal
application of our laws
well number one George Stephanopoulos
had no idea what I was talking about I
might as well have been talking to
Chinese he didn't know that Hillary
Clinton's people took a hammer to a
Blackberry he didn't know the uh White
the email is clean he didn't know that
Anthony Weiner wound up with classified
information on his computer he didn't
know any of that because when the
Democrats he used to say something they
don't know he needs to watch this show
he'll learn something yeah there you go
I I agree and happy birthday president
Trump because he's watching this joke
hey hey pal
yeah you have dinner with Melania and
Ivanka we got your back president Trump
we have your back this is not about you
it's about us
you could take the dolly lava and making
the Republican nominee that try to
destroy his life they hate conservatism
this is a bunch of BS president Trump
you're going to Prevail you're going to
be the Republican nominee and you're
going to be president again just hang in
there
to make
how is it possible the things you're
explaining you you don't believe the
George Stephanopoulos knew I give him a
little more credit than that I think he
knew damn well about the 33 000 deleted
emails he's not he's heard about bleach
bid he's heard about hammers uh
destroying blackberries and iPhones they
know all about it and yet they protect
their own and they're willing to have a
complete double standard because the
media is basically an extension of all
things you know radical new green deal
Democratic Socialist Party are they not
right yeah okay uh John McCain was great
until he became the nominee then he was
a crazy old man Mitt Romney uh was a
heartless billionaire who put the dog on
top of the car here's what I want to
tell every Conservative Republican what
do you like Trump or not it is not about
Trump if you're pro-life and you believe
in responsible gun ownership and you
want to limit the role of the Federal
Government you're the enemy of the
people president Trump was one hell of a
president on all the things that I care
about they're trying to destroy his life
it's not going to work and here's what's
coming next watch for an indictment in
Washington D.C you could convince you
could convict any Republican in America
of anything in Washington D.C he got
five percent of the vote here's what I
worry about that Mr Smith will indict
president Trump for January the 6th
activity in Washington D.C if he does
that that means he has no confidence in
the Florida case I hope and pray that Mr
Smith will not do that because that will
tear this country apart president Trump
has been treated unlike anybody I've
known in this business and I've been
around since 1995. what they hate about
him the most he's broken through to
working people he's the threat to the
left unlike anybody since Ronald Reagan
and Mr Mr president president Trump talk
about the future pal we got you back let
me ask you a last question
now you now we're talking about a New
York case with Alvin Braggs and you're
talking about a Miami case now you're
even now they've been mentioning all day
in New Jersey case now you're talking
about a Washington D.C case I have every
belief that you know just just like in
New York when you have AGS and and
prosecutors run on a campaign to go
after one man the same thing's going to
happen down in Fulton County Georgia how
do you vote for president with all of
those legal hurdles in front of you
that's not easy so Hillary Clinton said
something thing that was very I think
telling they have not yet broken
I can't believe they haven't broken
after this the goal is to find something
that will break us from Trump and the
reason they're not going to break us is
we see through this that if Donald Trump
took a hammer to a uh Blackberry it'd be
Front Page News the double standard is
real and they're literally trying to
find something to break the Republican
party from Donald Trump they fear this
man they fear his ability to come back
and turn America around they fear him
more than anybody else and that ought to
tell you something about President
Donald Trump the Democrats want to
destroy his life because they fear Him
and from my point of view
from my point of view
conservatism is in good hands with
President Donald Trump and that's his
biggest problem all right Senator
Lindsey Graham South Carolina thank you
for being with me hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else